if I can tell one thing to American
people its children just it's okay the
kids are going to smoke kids are going
to drink they're going to try some drugs
but in the end they're going to be fine
until a great country on April 22nd 2013
New York City Council Speaker Christine
Quinn announced a bill that would raise
the age to legally buy cigarettes from
18 to 21 recent TV visited NYU to ask
young adult smokers what they think of
the bill I think it makes about as much
sense as the drinking age being 21 so do
you think the drinking age to 21 makes
sense no why is that because I don't
believe that you should be able to fight
in the army and not be able to drink I
don't like the idea of controlling what
people can do harmful or otherwise to
their bodies talk to us about smoking
talk to us about fatty foods and sugary
drinks instead of just saying no you
can't have it because when you say that
it just makes you want to go out and try
it like be a rebel it might attract more
attention to cigarettes add more of a
cool factor to it and kids are trying to
illegal things they like from stupid
things and kids always find a way to get
what they need when did you start
smoking I'm like 16 so when the smoking
age was 18 it didn't stop you from
smoking no I started smoking when I was
in high school I started when I was 18
when I was a freshman here at NYU when I
was in middle school not very good but
yeah 11th grade
is there a age to buy cigarettes in
France there is but no one case I know
in Asian countries or even in Europe if
you like drink it's smoked at an earlier
age once you've hit the legal age people
don't go crazy but in the u.s. like once
you hit 21 people are going crazy
partying all night and they I don't know
they met their lives of age based
prohibition has proven to be an
ineffective deterrent to alcohol and
tobacco use
but if Christine Quinn succeeds Mike
Bloomberg as nanny and chief all New
Yorkers can expect to keep being treated
like children
you